our Kelly who is facing 10 counts of
sexual abuse involving four alleged
victims is scheduled to appear in a
Chicago Court this morning the R&B
singer remains in custody after
surrendering to police on Friday over
the weekend a judge set his bond at 1
million dollars
now that is two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars for each of the four
accusers
Jericka Duncan is outside the Cook
County Courthouse in Chicago Jericka
good morning good morning are Kelly's
attorney says the Chicago born singer is
expected to be released from jail after
this morning's hearing now Kelly's
attorney says that Kelly has been
scrambling to come up with that $100,000
that he needs to post bail but should
have the money later today he says
Kelly's been held in the hospital area
of the jail for security reasons but is
not sick or suicidal Kelly's charged
with 10 counts of aggravated criminal
sexual abuse against for women three of
whom were minors at the time of the
allegations which date back as far as
1998 prosecutors say they have a
videotape of Kelly having sex with a
girl believed to be 14 at the time and
they say they have DNA evidence in two
of those cases Kelly and his attorney
Steve Greenberg have consistently denied
any sexual misconduct the 52 year old
three-time Grammy winner is one of the
best-selling music artists of all time
allegations of Kelly's sexual abuse go
back at least two decades some of the
most recent of which aired in last
month's docu-series called surviving our
Kelly now Kelly was acquitted in 2008 on
child pornography charges but in these
latest cases if he were convicted on all
10 counts Nora he's looking at up to 70
years in prison
Nora will continue to watch at Trika
thank you